dans cette salle d'opération de
l'hôpital pierre boucher on s'apprête à
faire une chirurgie ici tous les
instruments sont stérilisés protéger
dans des emballages plastiques pour le
chirurgien c'est beaucoup de plastique
gaspiller mais on voit que le volume du
matériel qu'on utilise est très très
élevé on voit ça fait un grand volume de
matériel effectivement qui pourraient
être utilisés dans cet hôpital c'est
près de 40 tonnes de plastique médicaux
qui se retrouvent aux poubelles chaque
année pour équiper nos chirurgie on
utilise beaucoup beaucoup de plastique
que ce soit des emballages ce soit des
emballages pour nos fournitures de
papier bleu de solutés comme vous pouvez
voir ici dans la région de montréal ce
sont des centaines de tonnes de
plastique mythique coupe sont envoyés à
l'enfouissement chaque année selon recyc
québec il y a que quelques hôpitaux qui
les récupèrent alors que ce sont des
plastiques de qualité et que la plupart
ne sont pas comptés min sa fille
nathalie robitaille est une spécialiste
du développement durable selon elle les
hôpitaux doivent en faire plus pour
l'environnement façon générale environ
10% de leurs déchets malheureusement
plusieurs le plastique le son vous voyez
à l'enfouissement faute de filières de
récupération faut savoir que les places
etc hospitalier ne sont pas acceptés
dans les femmes des prix actuellement
c'est que les centres de tri ne prennent
que les plastiques qui proviennent de la
collecte sélective des municipalités
surtout quand on sait qu'il ya des
des objectifs gouvernementaux à
atteindre sauf qu'on n'a pas les moyens
tous les ans je n'ai pas de transport
beaucoup de ressources humaines ce n'est
pas leur priorité
disons de gérer les matières izel à
l'hôpital pierre boucher depuis quelques
temps on a commencé à récupérer certains
plastiques médicaux dont les sacs de
celui qui est toutefois ne sont pas
encore cyclables malgré le fait qu'ici
ils représentent 6 tonnes de déchets par
année et on est arrivé l'heure
d'aujourd'hui à faire un projet pour
recycler tout ce qui est des solutés ce
que l'on ne faisait pas les sacs de
shalit y compris sous le titre on voit
ici une fois triés par du personnel de
l'hôpital
on en voit notamment les sacs de ce
lutter ici dans cette usine où on fait
de la recherche et du développement pour
tenter de les recycler et de leur
trouver de nouveaux débouchés seul
premier dans mon domaine qui vraiment ça
n'irait dans le stage de matériaux plus
difficile qui viennent des hôpitaux puis
c'est pour ça que je travaille à cazaux
pour le réaliser oui des jt ou des
favoris comme on faisait avant mais il
ya déjà des clients qui sont - ils ont
cogné à ma porte pour l'aude et oui si
tu réussis à le faire nous autres ici a
réduit à trouver un acheteur pour cette
matière là bas on aurait été peut être
précurseur et on pourra récupérer
l'ensemble des sacs de solutés du québec
si on est capable de recycler puis
d'avoir des récupérateurs qui veulent
nos matières qui veulent éventuellement
des redevances sont là pour le papillon
le pour les métaux ont fait de l'argent
avec nos matières qu'on investit dans un
fonds vert qui nous sert à faire
d'autres initiatives en environnement le
chirurgien lexsi simon espère que
l'hôpital va poursuivre son virage vert
au cours des prochaines années
c'est quelque chose de très favorable
puisque ça entrave en rien les soins
qu'on offre aux patients mais ça permet
de laisser moins d'empreintes
écologique le sourne travail au
quotidien selon le ministère de la santé
il ya seulement sept établissements qui
ont un budget spécifique au
développement durable au québec
si jean philippe robillard radio canada
montréal